voilà alors on parlait évidemment des
pratiques à risque la pratique à risque
au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est d'être
simplement non porteurs d'un préservatif
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
les pratiques
maintenant il n'y a plus de groupe à
risque et la contamination bien
évidemment ne peut s'éviter qu'en
portant un préservatif et les autres
contaminations
enfin les autres les autres pratiques
c'est à dire le baiser le serment demain
etc etc on le rappellera jamais assez ne
ne contamine pas voulu dire quelque
chose que je vais enfin c'est une bêtise
c'est un truc bête que j'ai envie de
faire depuis depuis le début parce que
après tout on est là pour s'unir
les séropositifs les pas séropositif les
homosexuels les pommeaux sexuelle et
j'ai envie de faire un truc con mais
j'ai fini d'embrasser le monsieur que
derrière moi sur la bouche voilà il a de
la chance
karen et je suis sûr que dans son
angoisse ans a toujours nié leur la
démago et l'héroïne et tout ça c'était
juste une envie de jouer uniquement pour
que tout le monde comprenne enfin que je
ne suis pas contagieux je suis exigeante
éventuellement ces transmissibles pierre
connaît